Congress is expected to vote today on
another bailout bill to help businesses
slammed by the pandemic this comes amid
controversy over how government money
has been distributed so far some big
companies and well-endowed schools like
Harvard and Yale have returned bailout
money under pressure Nancy Cordes
reports on those who are still left out
we're down to like ten dollars Katie
Bell runs a spot in Arizona and has been
trying to get a small business loan
since the day the paycheck protection
program launched they've tried calling
reaching out I haven't been able to
actually talk to a real person yet I
haven't gotten any replies from any
emails yet she's hoping that the new
cash infusion will help three hundred
ten billion dollars Congress is set to
approve today after the first tranche of
250 billion ran out in just two weeks
sixty billion dollars will be aimed at
helping rural and minority-owned small
businesses and you have to give their
refunds
Varane rana singh owns a karate studio
in maryland he's applied for a PPP loan
three times but has heard nothing I
think the most frustrating part is seems
that the people who are meeting at the
most are not getting it big businesses
seems like they're the ones getting
nearly one point seven million PPP loans
have been approved so far by nearly
5,000 lenders but one survey found that
eighty percent of small businesses are
either still waiting to receive the
money or haven't even been told where
their application stands for major banks
are already facing a lawsuit alleging
they prioritized bigger customers
because those PPP loans yielded bigger
fees for the banks big corporations like
Ruth's Chris and potbelly secured their
funds even as smaller businesses waited
burger chain Shake Shack returned its
money to avert a backlash the owner of
this Auckland catering company says
he's not counting on ever getting the
aid we had to kind of take matters in
our own hands and we ended up hitting
our company to a direct-to-home grocery
delivery service so that we could
continue to employ there are 40 plus
employees the administration has
announced that the government is going
to be providing funds to hospitals to
help them cover the cost of treating
uninsured coronavirus patients health
secretary Alex azar yesterday declined
to say how much money would be given to
the hospitals but he did call it quote
more than sufficient Tony all right
Nancy thank you very much